[Applaudissements]
comment ça va
très beau c'est très beau vous êtes très
beau ce soir
comment ça va notre gueule
ça c'est dans un instant d'abord est-ce
que vous rappelez de votre stagiaire
Cyril Zakaria bien sûr Zakaria oui c'est
l'homme qui est capable de passer d'un
costume de Chantal Goya un costume de
rat en trois secondes il est devenu star
Zakaria et il va bientôt nous quitter
du coup
on a voulu créer une cagnotte pour sa
carrière et on a testé la générosité des
chroniqueurs générosité entre guillemets
bien sûr on les a testés du plus
généreux au plus crevard autant vous
dire qu'il y en a beaucoup plus dans la
partie crevard
[Musique]
on fait une petite cagnotte pour le
départ de Zakaria le stagiaire tu veux
mettre combien
je peux donner des petits restos
j'en ai récemment
[Musique]
mais vous doutez bien celui qui a peu de
voir même rien donné c'est évidemment le
crevard en chef Mathieu Delormeau
j'ai pas eu le temps de m'attacher
vraiment et
tu lui diras un petit mot ouais je
dirais un petit mot et je peux dire que
notre adresse moi je l'adore ils
comprennes que l'école de la vie se
faire tout seul pas compter sur les
autres c'est aussi comme ça qu'on
réussisse mais ce qui a pire crevard que
Mathieu Delormeau dans l'équipe non vrai
c'est pas possible et bien si pourtant
et c'est pas celui qui gagne le moins
vous voulez participer
je vais parler je vais parler je lui ai
parlé je vais parler non mais oh le but
c'est pas que les moum se barre après tu
es avec 10000 balles après un mois de
stage hein ça va
Daniel qu'elle donne plus de mettre 50
Daniel mais croissant
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
il y a une tension entre deux figures
emblématiques de la Star Ac cette
semaine une qui est un peu plus figure
emblématique que l'autre c'est
Jean-Pascal Lacoste et Mathieu Delormeau
devinerait
ça chauffait entre les deux sur le
plateau mais ça a chauffé encore plus
pendant la pub c'est à deux doigts de
partir en sucette complet c'est pas
possible
[Musique]
c'est une histoire qui a commencé sur
une émission à succès qui faisait 400000
téléspectateurs Jean-Pascal il a
acceptérant tout le prime mais quand
j'ai dit viens en parler je veux pas
mais non
[Applaudissements]
l'homme providentiel les deux
protagonistes se sont retrouvés sur une
émission à succès qui faisait 2 millions
de téléspectateurs
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est donc ton émission la seule ça va
mettre un trou du cul donc quand on sait
pas on ferme sa gueule
arrête tes conneries là
pas tais-toi
la coupure pub est arrivée ce qui était
propice à faire redescendre la tension
entre nos deux compagnons oh là là quel
casse-couille
non c'est toi qui a un gros con
[Rires]
la nuit porte conseil et Mathieu s'en
est extrêmement venu de son attitude
[Applaudissements]
ce qui est bien c'est que du coup
maintenant il a plus TPMP
[Applaudissements]
mais quel dommage pour Jean-Pascal qui
ne pourra plus faire TPMP people avec
Benoît Dubois
[Applaudissements]
je pense que vous avez dit ça sur
l'ambiance bien sûr
on a voulu mais pour le vrai vrai
celui-là il a peu mais celui-là j'ai pas
fâché non mais ça
va ça va ça va ça revient il est grande
gueule comme moi c'est fini
tu me fais un rideau tout de suite c'est
vrai bah oui bon on fera un rideau
quand même
il est 19h12 12 comme les douze coups de
mais oui
mon ami à Marseille
alors on va regarder les douze coups de
base c'est tout ce qui se passe pendant
les pubs pendant les magnétos raconter
par notre ami Jean-Luc c'est pas
possible
[Musique]
transit transit
on passe à la prédiction du jour quel
audience va bien faire face à Baba
écoutez le voyant je pense qu'on va
faire 800 mais tu m'as dit on va rien
faire
je crois pas je crois que la politique
moi je prends Suisse en mille combien
800000 moi je vous dis vous verrez je
connais bien les audiences
[Musique]
merci à vous d'avoir été aussi nombreux
plus d'un million 200000 personnes pour
face à babaye
je connais bien les audiences
[Musique]
on continue avec les citations
philosophique du jour le signe Baba
tu sais je vais te dire ça sert à rien
d'être très riche je mangerai pas de
steaks
[Musique]
moi je regarde le booster
la chansonnette et il crée même des
paroles en direct ouais c'est un piège
et je le dis au rédaccess oui je lui dis
que j'ai envie d'yes
j'ai envie de faire caca
mou ouais
elle t'a convaincu ou pas
une prime d'assiduité comme elle dit
Raymond siège dessus les gens font ça
normal d'aller bosser tous les jours
excusez-moi une prime c'est toujours
meilleur que de rien voilà en direct tu
as la diarrhée
mais c'est pas grave je t'aime comme ça
et vous avez donc de caca mou ah non non
c'est pas vraiment à lui ah tout le
monde c'est voilà c'est un caca mou
c'est voilà
non mais non mais parce que
voilà
donc oui et donc Cyril vous savez c'est
un puit d'idée et regardez et bien ce
que ça lui a donné comme idée pendant la
pub et celui qui est à côté de moi voit
très bien où je vais revenir
[Applaudissements]
appelez-moi je vous appelle tout de
suite
regardez regardez regardez appelez-moi
j'arrive amène-toi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est magnifique
grâce à Cyril Hanouna hier pendant la
pub mais quand je vous dis un tube c'est
pas genre ça va rester 2 minutes ça a
été remix c'est le tube de l'hiver et
c'est là qui est incroyable après TPMP
il est allé direct il a filé dans le
studio Cyril c'est incroyable c'est un
nouveau tube c'est incroyable
pour le tube de l'année ça s'appelle
caca mou faites entrer dans
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est insupportable ce mec
[Applaudissements]
c'est qui c'est caca c'est incroyable on
peut la remettre s'il vous plaît
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est insupportable ce mec
tout le monde
[Musique]
merci merci
[Applaudissements]
Quentin
alors qui était aujourd'hui Katia
[Applaudissements]
il y aura demain un nouveau personnage
qui se cachera derrière caca mou à vous
de le découvrir merci merci
tu seras votre nouvelle star nouveau
caca mou demain merci frérot tu pourras
mettre sur la porte de stage
ah il est incroyable merci aux danseuse
merci merci ma chérie merci merci
[Applaudissements]